[Music]
thank you
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host Dr Greg Sadler today we're
talking about examining the ethical
dimensions of a-holary and everybody
knows what we mean by a-hole we're gonna
try to keep it I'm not sure if it's PG
or G by not saying the word over and
over and over again but what we're
looking at are the aita
Forum or Reddit rather subreddit
subreddit there you go and we've got
some cases picked out that we're gonna
plow through and make our own judgments
on and you can go you know to the
subreddit and check these out these are
all from the last week or so so easy
enough I think to find and we've talked
about this before in the past we devoted
three other episodes number 30 41 and 53
to aita that is am I the a-hole
um Reddit posts and they're they're
really fun to explore so we thought we'd
do another one it's been a while right
so so we should talk about you know just
as a refresher for our listeners what
are a i t a post and you spend more time
on Reddit I think than I do Dan don't
you personally or fortunately depending
on the circumstances yeah so
um it is a server in which people you
know make their case they say like this
situation happened
um and they give information that ask
the community am I the a-hole the
question is like how much of this
information are we getting are they
providing you the full view of the
events we don't know so what we're
trying to do is only from the
information it's given
um you know what is the initial
impression as well as maybe like okay
what would be some things that
potentially would change this
um but regardless of that we will at
least from the initial impression give a
an answer of you know not the a-hole
um uh yes the a-hole no one's the a-hole
or everyone CA home I like that last one
um you know everyone sucks yeah there
are some some situations where you're
like wow what you what you did what you
chose was really a bad idea but it does
make sense that you chose it because
that other person over there is a jerk
and the other people who were weighing
in on it are also jerks and it just kind
of expands and we should point out too I
mean this is social media so so people
do weigh in on these and then sometimes
the original poster will clarify
something or get into a an argument a
sub-argument with the other people who
are saying something about it right and
um I I use Twitter more than read it
myself and I see quite a few of these
make their way into Twitter and come in
for discussion there as well
I wonder if there's other social media
where this is happening
do you do you happen to just gotta I
don't know but like maybe Instagram or
you know who knows uh world star
um but I guess the thing that we also do
that's kind of unique in these episodes
is we're going to try to give some sort
of uh moral Foundation to why we are
going to make these things you know we
could go from
um some sort of deontological or on
virtue based or contractualism or on
utilitarianism you know you can find a
whole bunch of like basices and we'll
kind of like you know give why these
things fit into these categories yeah
we're not just shooting from the hip you
could say right we I mean we may be
wrong but yeah some justification for
for what we're saying and you know the
aita subreddit
it does pose itself as being sort of
like an applied space for moral
philosophy they've got this description
a catharsis for the frustrated moral
philosopher in all of us and a place to
finally find out if you were wrong in an
argument that's been bothering you tell
us about any non-violent conflict you've
experienced give us both sides of the
story and find out if you're right or if
you're the a-hole and I I kind of like
that the frustrated moral philosopher in
all of us sort of implying that whether
you've taken an ethics class or had some
sort of Ethics training or you know
whatever all of us are a moral
philosopher the question is whether
we're good ones or not right right
we all have like this like feeling like
we have
different things that like just give us
a gut feeling if that is wrong
um and uh you know people are going to
respond to those and certain people will
respond more negatively to certain
things than others
um yeah it's quite true but uh uh what
we're trying to do here is to try to at
least systematize those uh feelings into
something that is uh
can actually be categorized we're trying
to bring more light than heat you could
say right there we go yes you know it'll
be the LEDs not the incandescent bulbs
there you go yeah and you know when we
think about why we classify people as
jerks a-holes pick whatever you want
creeps could be another thing in some of
these cases so as Dan was mentioning
there's a lot of moral theory or ethical
perspectives we can look at things from
and we'll explain them along the way but
generally there's going to have been
some sort of something went wrong right
there's a there's a conflict there's a
dilemma there's some sort of violation
of a norm or something was given
priority when it shouldn't have been
um or sometimes people seem to lack
common sense or decency and then you
know there's also the question of as you
mentioned how the story is framed
sometimes people will read it and
they'll be like you just sound like a
jerk the way you're talking about this
why did you choose these words why did
you say it
this way and and I think there's also in
some of the cases we're going to look at
there's people who they get into a
conflict they could resolve it but they
don't and then it turns into a grudge or
it turns into a guilt trip or it turns
into people not speaking to each other
giving each other the cold shoulder and
so that the conflicts get perpetuated
and you know actually we should we
should think about this why do you think
like it I wouldn't go on to Reddit
myself and put a case there and say what
do you think world I mean would you do
that Dan with any of the things you've
gone through
no I usually will ask people that I have
close relationships that I want you know
that I feel like you're going to give me
an honest review but like there's
it's interesting that there's a point of
like anonymity where people like I don't
care yeah like they're not trying to
help you like you know coddle you or
anything they're gonna just give you
what they want I don't know it's just I
think the it only works because of the
anonymity okay we're asking a lot of
people that you knew I'd only asked a
very small subset of the people that I
knew to try to get me some really good
advice uh but yeah it's it's a I guess
I'd do it answer your question
I don't know well I don't know that I I
don't I don't know that I would go on
there I like the idea of asking close
friends people whose opinions I value
I'm although I will admit and I've done
it
jokingly I have had a few times where
I've gone on Twitter and other social
media and said
um so you know somebody wants me to do x
y z I don't want to do it because of
this what what do you think about that
you know for example and this may come
across as very Petty to some people
um
I don't like people calling
things podcasts that don't actually have
like an RSS feed or an MP3 file I think
you know so like some people have a
video channel and they'll call it the
such and such podcast and then they'll
invite me on as a philosopher for you
know whatever it's going to be and I'll
look you know I'll put it in Google and
I'll look to see whether there's an
actual podcast somewhere like on Apple
podcast or Spotify or SoundCloud or
whatever right and there isn't really
it's just the YouTube channel and then
I'll be like you don't really have a
proper podcast do you and they'll you a
lot of times people are kind of bemused
about this they're like well no it's
it's a podcast and I'll be like podcast
means there's a sound file somewhere
this is just a video recording you know
what it why are you billing it is that
and it was interesting when I put that
out there there were a lot of people and
so I did it in YouTube my YouTube
channel I did it in uh Twitter and in
Facebook and there were a lot of people
who wait did and they're like who the
hell are you to call things a podcast or
not and I was like well there is a
definition of it you know
um we can't just make words mean
whatever the hell we want like Humpty
Dumpty you know we uh we should probably
call Things by their proper names and
they were so offended that I was taking
you know uh exception to calling things
podcasts they were it was it was like
way over the top you know and then there
were other people who are like you must
Define podcasts strictly or else you may
not do that as it's like at The Other
Extreme
um so I had a long story short I have
actually gone to the internet sometimes
to see whether not whether I was being
the the a-hole although I suppose I
could have you know been classified as
one for turning people down uh but
rather whether I was I guess you could
say whether I was the being pedantic or
whether I was rightly insisting on words
meaning what they mean you know
I guess
um have you ever done anything like that
or
not turned down something like that over
that I guess the way you you can choose
to to filter out requests however when
you want to like if that is your your
criteria that is totally up to you
um you know if well I do I do I do
actually have something kind of lurking
in the back of my head saying if you
can't actually use language more or less
correctly and you want to double down
you're probably not going to be a good
host and it's not going to be a good use
of my time oh well that that is an
interesting and actually useful like uh
assertion Freak no um uh uh indicator
okay for which I think is I don't have
any problem with that yeah but what I
was asking though is have you like put
something out there on the internet I've
asked people for okay
uh but I don't think I would have any
particular qualms against it
well you just need a good moral dilemma
then right right
um but uh we should jump maybe next time
we'll have one so we should yeah we
should go in so we've got um one here
um about paying rent
um to your parents so uh this is from
um the title is am I the a-hole for
moving out after my parents told me to
pay rent no
starting off okay like okay maybe this
is weird yeah um so I'm at I 19 moved
out of my parents house about a year ago
there was nothing wrong in my life I had
a good upbringing I loved being home and
I had a lot of friends and parents were
loving or so I thought anyways I was
going to have a big 18th birthday and as
is the legal age where I stay Australia
and means to go from boy to man child to
adult I had a venture rented out and I
had family and friends come over from
all over to celebrate with me we had a
blast at night I had my first drink and
almost made it my last I don't remember
anything from that night but from the
photos I've seen it looks like I had a
good night so I was happy a day after
that night my parents sat me down to
have a talk they told me that
I'm a man now and that I've been working
a lot of hours yet they haven't received
anything they told me that as soon as I
started working they expected me to help
pay rent obviously I did not know and
and any of that because I didn't get
told they told me that I should have
known better but now that I'm 18 they
expect me to help with rent honestly I
didn't mind helping if they'd asked I
was 16 when I got my first job at
McDonald's and am now working
construction but they made it seem like
I was in the wrong for not giving them
money and I was where they and I get
where they're coming from but from a
young boy's perspective all I saw was
green all I saw was a triple digit
paycheck that I wanted to spend right
away anyways I told them I'd start
helping them from now on but it wasn't
good enough for them they told me that I
had to pay them back all the money that
I should have been giving them when I
first started working which was almost
10 10K I said no flat out and they got
mad they told me that either I pay rent
and pay them back or they are what they
are owed or I move out and buy my own
place so that's what I did I moved out a
few days after to my friend's house for
a bit until I found my own apartment I
have been living here for about eight to
ten months as soon as I moved out I got
bombarded with calls and texts saying
that I just
disrespected them by not paying them
what they owe and making it harder for
them to live now that they don't have
someone washing or doing their laundry
taking out the rubbish and all those
little stuff they are both in their
early 40s and more than capable of doing
it yeah this is an interesting one
there's a there's a couple different
wrinkles to this right right so what's
what's your verdict like we should
actually like weigh in on each of these
and then we'll we'll go into more detail
about it so what's what's your group
General verdict not the [__] yeah I
and actually I would say I would go so
far as to say the parents are you know
yes yeah very clearly uh for a couple
reasons so one thing that I was thinking
about when I was reading this is if
you're going to make ultimatums and
somebody actually calls your bluff you
can't complain if you've set out what
the ultimatum is it's sort of like you
know if I were to say
um if I were to go to my my school and
I'm like unless you pay me more you're
gonna have to fire me and then okay
we'll fire you you know well I didn't
really mean it that way or you know that
doesn't work once you actually like put
the words on the table and that's what
they did with the you got to pay us back
10 grand from your 16 to 18 year old you
know not paying us thing or move out and
then he says fine I'll move out you know
uh I don't think they get to complain
after that
no not at all like okay
it's one thing like if you told someone
up front and you're like you know if you
want to go into like you know uh
contract theory or whatnot yeah yeah uh
you know like you you set out the things
beforehand you don't get to
retroactively say oh you know uh you you
already owe this from a thing that
there's no contract for so that's that's
not going to you know fly in that regard
not to mention like uh you're you're 16
to 18.
um I guess I assume but I'm not quite
sure that you're still in on high school
high school yeah
why are you making your kid pay ten
thousand dollars from two years of
working at McDonald's in high school
that seems like a rather large portion
of that person's wage
um there's another weird thing too and
the fact the very end of it where he
says they don't have someone washing or
doing their laundry taking out their
rubbish and all those things uh and it's
making it harder for them to live so
presumably even when he was 16 and
working this job he was doing these
other things which is contributing to
the household it's really uncompensated
labor that they also want from this kid
you know right so it seems like
and also this last sentence he says that
they're in their early 40s yeah this kid
is 18 on they obviously had their kid on
in their early 20s I don't know if they
have other kids but at least that's one
they had in their early 20s
um did they are they like in Arrested
Development do they think that their kid
was just like indentured labor like yo
yeah uh it's maybe there's something
weird with uh being as was it Austria
um but Australia Australia yeah
um
like I don't know
the kangaroo meet does something to you
I think these are just jerk parents
quite frankly that are kind of I mean
the kid sounds more mature than the
parents in many respects and I think
you're you mentioned like if you're
going to expect something from somebody
you can't
you can't expect them to be a mind
reader right you have to actually like
lay out what your expectations are and
they did that you know they told me I'm
a man now and and they haven't received
anything
um but then you know the other line is
they told me as soon as I started
working they expected me to help pay
rent and he says obviously I didn't know
any of that because I didn't get told
um well if you don't tell them
especially you know when there's a power
imbalance and a maturity difference it's
on the parents to make this stuff clear
to the kid it's not up to him to like
you know research and figure out what
his parents wants right
and unless there's like some really
strong ingrained cultural thing where
like kids are supposed to pay their
parents and like everyone just knows
that like there's
I I don't see anywhere myself
me neither but like that'd be the only
like caveat that'd be like really change
this yeah
I will mention I began paying rent when
I was 17 to my to my mom and she was
very upfront with it it was in part
because I once I finished high school
and I was 17 when I finished high school
because my birthday's in August
um she had been getting Social Security
survivor benefits because my dad had
died when I was 11 and so as a widow she
got a certain amount per month and
um what she expected me to contribute it
wasn't much it was it was at that time
so we're talking about the late 80s it
was around 300 you know and I mean I was
eating way more than that in groceries I
can tell you that right not to mention
all the other things that went into it
um and she was you know she came up to
me and she was like okay so you're done
with high school and the Social Security
checks are they're gonna still come for
your your sister but they're not going
to come for you and I need you to start
you know helping out and I I was working
I was working at that time at Ponderosa
uh in Waukesha and I I was like yeah
okay that's that's fine you know I mean
it was a sizable part of my paycheck but
it was also quite reasonable for her to
ask you know but everything was like
start taking some steak from Ponderosa
as well well this there's a whole other
story to tell about that I mean one of
the things that was really quite funny
was so you know I was working on as a
grill cook and dishwasher and all that
and we're cooking these steaks and they
they'd you know they wouldn't cook right
some of the time and then suddenly they
they started this ad campaign and
they're like we're now serving grade A
steaks and we're like well what the hell
were we cooking before
right because yeah they had changed the
quality
um and and actually we would sometimes
have cookouts after work and I think we
did sometimes take some of the stakes
and stuff and cook them up
but I I think that's par for the course
if you're working you know restaurants
yeah yeah
um so uh shall we go to the next one
here sure so I'll I'll read this one uh
given that I can relate to it am I uh
the a-hole for telling my students my
contract wasn't renewed I 23 year old
female had a long-term sub position at a
school in my city parallel to my master
studies I'm studying to be a teacher I
had four classes since the beginning of
the school year my contract ends in two
and a half weeks and there will be five
more weeks until summer holidays prior
to the Easter vacation the administrator
told me I was definitely staying and
getting a renewed contract until the
summer holidays last week it turned out
it won't be renewed because of reasons
like there's no actual reason I'm sad
about it and I told my students I would
no longer be there and when my contract
will end exactly so they can plan ahead
I'm actually on good terms with all four
classes but two of them seem to like me
really really really much when I told
them they said it's not fair and that
they want to keep me I said while I also
want to keep you but it's not my
decision but I'm happy to have met you
well a few kids decided to make it their
decision and told their parents a good
handful of students and parents went to
admin and told them what they thought
about this not renewing my contract I
received a bitter mail from admin that
it was unprofessional to tell the
students and was told from a teacher
that is close to admin that it's an
a-hole move of me was it so this is
somebody who's kind of doubtful about
you know whether they
crossed the line whether they did the
wrong thing or not yeah
total
like this was really quite easy for me
and like especially this
whoever this other teacher this close to
admin is like just Towing the admin line
yeah I mean would you say that the admin
is being an a-hole in this case in
saying giving the bittered note saying
it was unprofessional to tell the
students
um I think that the more a holy thing
was the saying that she was going to be
employed and then
reneging on that particular uh agreement
okay
um only to
um
uh not even have any reason to do it
yeah
so there's two possible reasons why the
admin person is is really an a-hole in
this case
I mean I don't think that it's
unprofessional
to tell the students and I think a lot
of cases uh professional gets gets
abused as a concept to try to keep
people in line
you know if you're going to let somebody
go I think at that point you don't have
any expectation any reasonable
expectation that they're not going to
tell other people that
unless they like signed an NDA or
something you know exactly that's my
only other thing is like unless it's in
the contract once again like you know
going back to like contracts yeah yeah a
contractualism or or like just contract
law like unless it's been predetermined
that you will not disclose any terms of
your employment with the students then
you know I I there's no professional
place that I see as well as like as
you're saying look at this is the using
the type of the thing professionals like
it's not professional to talk with your
uh other employees about your wages but
it is protected by law and even though
lots of employers will say that it's
like illegal to talk to or you can't
talk about that otherwise you might get
fired no that's uh BS that's total BS
and it's all these things to try to you
know make sure there's a very little
blowback for the decisions that the
administration is making themselves yeah
I think you could say that the
administrator kind of wants to have it
both ways right there and this is
actually a larger topic they're
expecting something like loyalty
from the employee in this case the
teacher but they're not showing any
loyalty to them and you do see this in a
lot of
um narcissistic or abusive people right
they loyalty only goes one way
so all right so what are all
corporations narcissists
well no I think it would be more a
matter of the particular managers or
Executives the people who are expecting
this this sort of thing I mean let's
let's say we take this in a corporate
Direction so
would we say that if somebody's on a
renewable contract
and then they maybe they get like a bad
performance review right
and their boss tells them okay you're
you're going to be fired in three weeks
you're we're letting you go right
it wouldn't make sense to say well you
can't say anything about this to anybody
right
uh your fellow employees or
people that that could be contacts to
find you another job or something so why
would it why would it be the same in
terms of a teacher
I don't know also like most most
corporations are gonna say that you're
you got three weeks you're just gonna
say and this is your last day yeah pack
up your stuff and leave but
I don't know it's it's interesting like
if if you're going to follow that script
then
uh I guess it would make sense for you
not to even tell her until like it's
already passed but that's okay but then
you're really leaving her in the Lurch
right oh yeah like uh it's it's much
more of an [__] move in my opinion
but it's uh it would make sense from the
like I want the little the smallest
amount of blowback possible but what
they're trying to get here and they're
angry that they're getting any blowback
in the first place yeah yeah
I guess this is a question it's like
it's is it easier to ask permission or
to ask forgiveness and you know if they
had been
fired or let go yeah
um then they'd be like asking
forgiveness whereas now you've told them
beforehand and now they're like oh you
know the students as well as their
parents who have some sway over the
administration
now we can weigh in on this topic I mean
I think that's another interesting
feature of this case too is she didn't
go to the administrator and say you know
my students are upset or something she
just told her students and the students
got upset and then the students talked
to their parents who are the
stakeholders who you know maybe are
paying tuition or something like that
right and she didn't like tell the
parents hey I'm doing a campaign to try
to keep my job or something the parents
took it on their own initiative to go to
the administrator and express their
their uh concerns or grievances or
whatever it's going to be right so there
were a different agent than than she is
right and so like I guess if she was
like riling up her students or yeah
talking to the parents and and trying to
inform them to do this thing then it
might be slightly different but you know
like she's she's not
instigating directly that uh someone
contacted the administration yeah I
think when you give information to
somebody else
and there's no deception there's no
coercion you know you're just giving
them the straight information and then
they go and act on that information
you're especially if it's information
that they deserve to have right the
students would like to know that the
teacher is going to be there now now
it's important information you're not
responsible for what that other person
does with that information you didn't
like set them up to go and you know oh
let's burn the building down or
something like that
not to mention I think it would actually
be an a-hole move to not tell your
students you know is it the teacher
student relationship interesting there's
a lot of trust that usually goes with
that particular relationship and if
you're just like yep bye never see you
or see you maybe
um that seems to be a a breach of that
trust or a breach of the expectations of
that relationship yes you know I as an
adjunct somebody who teaches part-time
for different institutions I have had
students come to me
um at places besides Milwaukee Institute
of Art and Design where I have sort of
like continuing expectation of of uh
working there which is a you know nice
security to have I've had students come
up to me and they're like oh I liked
your class I'd like to take another
class with you and then I have to say
well I don't know what I'm going to be
teaching if I'm even going to be
teaching here again and then they're
always like both disappointed but also
super surprised because I think most of
them don't
they don't understand
how it works in contemporary Academia
that
um
most of the people doing the teaching
are not you know tenure track having
reliable expectation of getting rehired
all the time you know all right
let's
kind of Spain but I think we need to
talk about support dogs sure why don't
you read this one all right so uh it
might be a hill for uninviting a
bridesmaid to my wedding because of her
support dog
spicy
four contexts me and Amy have been
friends since elementary school were no
longer that close but we still keep in
touch and she actually introduced me to
my fiance in college so I asked her to
be a bridesmaid the first time we met
Amy brings Spud her really cute pug
unfortunately I'm really allergic to
dogs I mentioned this to her she says
that he has to accompany her because
he's her emotional support dog
I'm not very knowledgeable on sub
support animals but I respect their
roles so I try to accept it but by the
end of the day I'm a mess just
disgusting and I feel awful I pull Amy
aside and ask if there are any ways she
can leave Spud at home for the next
meeting she becomes upset sitting that
for health reasons he has to accompany
her and I have I back down but after two
more meetings
all the uh two more meetings though I
can't do it because I just feel too sick
I pull her aside and I tell her that I
can just can't be in the same room as
Spud she mentions she already brought
him a little suit for the wedding
I inform her that there's just no way he
can come my ceremony is in a tiny church
and he and I will inevitably be in close
proximity
this kicks off a big discussion about
the importance of support animals and
mental health I completely agree that
mental health is significant and
understand that Spud is helping helpful
to her but in the context of my wedding
I just can't be around a dog she asks if
she had a medical condition like
seizures or diabetes and needed Spud to
help her survive if I would kick him out
I admitted that I would have to think
about it she stated that this is an
example of ableism and that his role is
just as important
I then ask if he can come to the wedding
that I ask that if he can come to the
wedding but can stay outside with his
partner or something for the ceremony
and then just
join her for the reception which is
outside
she asks alternatively if I can just
take an antihistamine for the ceremony I
let her know that they don't work for me
completely and I get really groggy so
I'd rather not for another event I
consider it but for my own wedding I
just don't want to make that kind of
compromise
I had a few more exchanges with her and
neither of us is budging I then tell her
that if she insists on bringing Spud to
the ceremony I'm going to ask her not to
attend she is upset and tells the rest
of the wedding party whose opinions are
split another bridesmaid is now refusing
to go unless I reinvite Spud I have
still refused so now both Amy and this
bridesmaid have venmoed me for the cost
of the dresses and Spud suit I paid them
but they are still taking a talking to
more guests at the wedding about it I'm
just still exhausted I'm torn between
annoyed at the impact this is happening
on my own wedding but also the concern
that I have made a cruel decision I'm
wondering if the right thing to do was
to stuck it up and let him come am I the
a-hole
what do you think Greg I think that
she is definitely not the a-hole that
she's been super accommodating and I
think that her friend is and I think the
other bridemate is too you know and that
they're one of the things that's really
telling us that they're you know it's
resolved they've both got their money
back and they still want to keep on
talking to other people about the
wedding they're so they're agitating
yeah they're trying to Poison the Well
you know
uh
and I was really you know rereading this
so her friend accuses her of ableism
right which is an easy thing to throw
around right but her friend is being
ableistic too right or ableist because
she's expecting somebody who has
allergies to put up with the the
provoker the cause of the allergies
right right
uh not to mention the thing that's like
okay you are invited to become part of
the wedding party yeah this is not a uh
obligation that the bride has to give to
anyone
um as well as uh it like
you were there as a a guest you know
like you're supposed to help out or
whatnot but like it is that's just an
honor and not anything that is
um deserved yeah
um just outright so like neither of
these bridesmaids
um have any like claim to like I have to
be in this position they might want it
but there's no like you've taken
something to that uh I deserve away from
me yeah I guess that's the first thing
um then but yeah secondly yeah
specifically the that they're they got
all their money back they've been asked
to leave they weren't on especially
after being accommodating and they're
they're trying to turn guests and and
ruin this wedding I would call that
trying to ruin the wedding at this point
in time there's one thing of like yeah
I'm upset but I'm gonna leave it be
um but you're you're actively going out
there and trying to make things worse
they're essentially retaliating right
um so they're they're continuing the
conflict rather than
allowing it to and I I think this person
has been very accommodating too I mean
she's proposing several different
solutions to the issue without just
saying hey your dog can't be there your
dog could be outside you know
um and her friend just won't uh
won't
consider these these compromises you
know
it's just it feels
I don't know like
like she feels like she's I guess
entitled to this position or she
deserves this thing the friend the
friend yes yes okay the bridesmaid I
guess the other one that decided into
solidarity
um yeah I I can't see anything that the
the bride did that was uh
you know how she put it on a cruel
decision there was nothing cruel here
it's interesting with several of these
cases that we've looked at so far
um these are people who are
not an a-hole and are worried about
whether they are right so they they're
they're
concerned whether they did something
wrong
you know
um so I guess you know let's go to let's
find an actual thing so I'm gonna bring
up like virtue ethics
um
okay what what is it to be virtue ethics
deals with being excellent at things
like trying to be yeah and having
certain
um characteristics or qualities that one
cultivates that exhibit that Excellence
you know and and I would say her friend
is being vicious
you know retaliating in being sort of
egotistical insisting on having things
her way
um but I would say the bride is I mean I
don't know what her characters really
like but what she's showing in this is
being accommodating I mean like you
pointed out it's her day right so she is
the most important person and yet she's
willing to try to propose these
compromises so her friend can be in the
wedding you know
um I mean what would we call that being
considerate
um yeah accommodating yeah yeah
um being Equitable is how Aristotle
would actually talk about it you know
yeah
um you know she's trying to be just the
situation of like seeing what her needs
are and to you know accommodate for
those needs but um you know no
compromise can be made and once the
compromise cannot be made then
um yo the
bridesmaids acting vicious in
retaliation on the shows like a feeling
of vindictiveness as well as
um specifically like trying to destroy
the thing that you were once part of
yeah
I was thinking we should do another
wedding thing but you mentioned uh we
should look at one where somebody
probably is the a-hole so I'm gonna
bring one up like that and read it and
ah I think
this one's pretty straightforward
am I the a-hole for telling my daughter
to work out now the title by itself
no right but the situation so I 47 year
old male have a 16 year old daughter me
and her mother don't mention her weight
much but she refuses to work out she
sits in her room 24 7 on her phone stays
up until four takes naps and eats
throughout the day sometimes eating
snacks in the middle of the night me and
my wife told her to go for a 30 minute
walk every day but she doesn't listen to
us she says she will but she never does
just adding on to her unhealthy habits
she's also grown two to three inches in
the past two years and gained a lot more
weight she's at a regular weight now but
it's slightly increasing every
appointment
we're sitting at dinner when we're
having a debate about how digestion
Works weird topic it makes more sense
with context we move to metabolism and I
told her she's visibly gained weight and
she needs to work out and cut down a bit
and how she never works out and it would
be best for her she left the table and
went to her room and my wife berated me
for that comment because Claire had
insecurities in the past she was also
crying and my wife told me I was an
a-hole for that comment but I said she
needed to work out for her health in
general and nothing we told her was
getting the job done am I the a-hole
I agree with the wife
yeah me too I mean it's one thing to
have concerns about health right it's
another to express them in a way that
you know is going to be hurtful and
insist on doing it that way
and I think one of the things that's so
telling though
she's at regular weight right now right
so this is somebody who is criticizing
his daughter
not for where she actually is but where
he's worried that she's going to be I
mean there's lots and lots of men also
women like this who give their kids
eating disorders by projecting this this
kind of thing onto them you know
yeah
I'm exactly there like she's at a normal
weight now on on yeah and he literally
calls her fat like you gained a lot of
weight
um if you're I don't know I I don't
think I've met a single 16 year old girl
that is going to react positively to
your parent telling you that right yeah
um and and some of this seems a little
bit
hyperbolic she sits in a room 24 7 on
her phone stays up till four takes naps
eats throughout the day
I mean we need a little bit more context
here and she's not going to school is
this in the summer you know what what's
going on here and I mean frankly
um teenagers do that kind of stuff I
mean right that's like that's normal
yeah I mean we stayed up as late as we
possibly could we like actually I
remember me and my buddy we tried to see
how long we could possibly go without
sleep you know before we would fall
asleep
and you know eating uh throughout the
day uh eating snacks in the middle of
the night
again uh I'm not gonna say all teenagers
do that or that it's healthy Behavior
but teenagers eat a lot more than than
adults do you know
and she's obviously actively growing
she's grown two to three inches in the
past two years you know she's eating
enough to you know at least provide for
her body the net necessary nutrients to
grow that much so yeah like if she's
grown two to three inches and she didn't
gain weight then you'd be worried right
right on and then this uh you know the
the only time is like is is she like
morbidly obese to the point where like
she's caught is causing her medical
issues right yeah then then you you need
to have some sort of intervention but
um go on and saying like you're fat it's
not going to help that it's like yeah
I mean it's interesting too because he
says that both
um he and his wife
have been trying to you know like tell
her to take walks and stuff like that
and are worried about but his wife can
at least recognize that he's being an
a-hole
right
and if you're gonna do that don't just
tell them to do that go and walk doesn't
he say like he goes for walks it's like
invite her to go walk with you that was
something that some of the people in the
comments said you know why there were
two things I thought that were very
interesting one is if you want her to
take walks you need to bring her along
on walks and the other was why are you
worried about her going to work out why
don't you find some sort of exercise
that she actually likes doing not
everybody likes going to the gym maybe
she'd like bicycling or you know
um I don't know throwing a ball around
or something like that
yeah I'm trying to think of like what's
a good
um you know ethical standard that we
could apply here
a care
um so and this is interesting because
so in a certain way he is being caring
by having concern and I mean it seems a
bit misplaced given some of the things
he says but you can be caring sometimes
in let's call it the directedness or the
orientation of what it is that you're
focusing on and then be totally uncaring
in the way that you approach somebody
about it you know I mean imagine if you
had like an alcoholic friend right and
you're like can't take you anywhere
alkie you know we don't want you getting
drunk all the time I mean that's that's
a terrible thing to say to somebody you
know
the first thing is you know there's a a
line that gets bandied about and some
quote from something it's like you're
not wrong you're just the [__]
and so like technically he's not wrong
right right and then the second thing is
like from
um Epictetus to the stove philosopher uh
in his discourses talks about
um the two handles that everyone has two
handles and one handle will uh break it
will not hold up the pot
um whereas the other one will uh you can
lift it and now there's
um you need to know how to approach each
individual person in a way that they
will actually uh be receptive to the
thing that you're saying to them yeah
that that is a that's a good uh
adage to bring up
everything has two handles one of them
the thing can be carried the other one
it can't be and you know especially when
you're dealing with younger people
um
I think some people think they they call
it tough love they think like being an
a-hole is somehow
going to like Snap them out of it
I mean I've I've I have to admit I've
tried that sometimes with my own kids
it's never worked
never for the long term I would get
compliance occasionally but
um it always did more damage to the
relationship than anything else you know
yeah are they complied because they
agree with you or because they don't
want you to be angry or they don't like
you being angry there you go yeah that's
right yeah
um can we uh skip to the the rent one
here sure yeah we can do that and then
maybe come back to the uh the other
wedding one which I think is very
interesting if we have sure okay so um
am I the a-hole for not wanting to pay
rent to my boyfriend
I'm 25 and moving in with my significant
other 30. he's owned his house for many
years and makes mortgage payments he can
more than afford it and makes five to
six times more salary than I do I'm
happy to contribute my half of groceries
utilities Etc but is asking for extra
rent even though I am not part of the
mortgage he didn't previously rent it
out or have any roommates it's a big
house I would also like to add that he
is the only the one who really wanted me
to move in with him I was on the fence
it would have been fine waiting another
year what do you think is fair question
um I think she should get the hell out
of there
right
I think this is right I think there's
red flags in this
um what what do you what do you say like
right now I would say on none no one's
the [__] yet because she hasn't moved
see this is a proposal and so like
there's like okay there's definitely
some weirdnesses here and unless he's
like this is the only way this is
happening and you have to move in then
be like yeah you're you're proposing a
really absolutely uh contract here yeah
um
if this is just like an initial proposal
that he hasn't really thought it through
then maybe not
um but I'm not quite sure about that see
if I can get the camera to actually get
me on on and uh
yeah uh I guess the other person is like
if he's
um
owns this place he's not putting you on
the rent and wants you to pay into it or
yeah um because it's putting you even if
you're not paying for it it's still also
bad because now you're in this position
of power where you're uh in a
relationship and it's not like you're
not married so you haven't like joined
finances or anything
um and now he's the sole person that's
providing you
um housing yeah yeah and
if it ever goes south then obviously
it's going to result in
um you not having the housing anymore I
mean the right term for somebody
uh whose mortgage you are helping to pay
uh without getting any Equity is your
landlord
right so I think he's he's proposing
that he become her landlord but also
remain her boyfriend lover whatever you
know partner whatever it's going to be
and I I don't think those are good
um
categories to mix up
not usually no I mean it's interesting
because my mother had an arrangement she
had a live-in boyfriend who had his own
business uh and he lived with her for 10
years and she owned her own house out in
Menomonee Falls
um there was a mortgage but she had it
she was like it was almost paid off by
the time that she sold it and then moved
to Brookfield shortly before she ended
up dying
and he had to pay
utilities uh some of the groceries
and uh property tax
yeah
um and then she paid all the rest of the
stuff right including like you know
upkeep you know the the kinds of you
know the plumber needs to be called in
she paid for all that sort of stuff and
I was like boy he's really skating by I
mean he gets the whole house basically
to do what he wants to do and and
um he doesn't have to pay rent he's he's
basically
um paying you know much smaller amount
of of money than he would be if he was
renting a place like this
um and she was cool with that you know
and I I sometimes ask her about that why
don't you charge him rent and she'd be
like well that wouldn't make sense you
know uh I'm not giving him any equity in
the house
it's sort of like what we talked about
before like with the guy's parents the
Australian guys this guy wants to have
things more than one way right
right
I like I like your idea though about
he's not yet the a-hole
yeah but should he put this into effect
he becomes one
so proposing it doesn't make him one
following through on it does
uh do you want to hit this wedding one
really quick yeah so this is this is one
I really quite like am I the a-hole for
being honest with my friends on why I'm
not having a wedding
I 31 female will be getting married
legally but have no interest in a
wedding I also don't have an engagement
ring my friends have always been
fascinated by why I've made these these
decisions as they have not been strictly
Financial ones and numerous times I've
brushed it off as just not for me after
yet again another round of questions and
assumptions about why I'm not doing
these things I was honest I personally
find it all pretty basic that we all
have identical weddings and wear
identical rings at least in my brain it
just isn't even close to being worth the
money for things that are so often so
unoriginal and I'm not interesting
enough to do something different I
couldn't care less what other people do
with all their money and I enjoy my
friend's wedding days and I am nothing
but positive about them I understand
people will all do similar things in the
sake of tradition which is why I do a
lot of things just this one isn't worth
the money for me personally based on
what I find Value in and enjoy my
friends are now really offended and are
saying saying that I called them basic I
think I'm allowed to have my own
opinions on stuff and they're not
allowed to take it so personally when
they've asked so many times I don't get
offended when my friends do things
differently to me for their own reasons
I need to know whether I should have
kept my mouth shut and or if I should
apologize and the key term here is the
term basic which you know some of our
listeners may not know has become a in
recent years a pejora derogatory yeah
it's you know it means like uh
simple or uninteresting or something
like that
I'm very I'm very sympathetic to her
I I would say the biggest a-hole here is
the wedding industry oh interesting yeah
yeah you're right I mean the average
wedding I if if I remember right these
days is something like fifty thousand
dollars and I am totally receptive to
this idea that that's a waste of money
on things that are essentially are
coming from an industry that just churns
this stuff out with what in economics
they used to call marginal
differentiation like how should your
dress look it's going to be white do you
want to have Frills here Frills here you
know do you want it to like have a long
train or a short train let's get you a
cake now how many layers is it gonna
have will there be a little bride and
groom on top blah blah blah blah blah
right all this nonsense do you want a
diamond ring with one or two or three
stones there you go yeah uh but it has
to be a diamond ring and that diamond
ring better SP because be the cost of
your the husbands
bridegrooms like three or two three
months okay three months yeah of income
that's this is an insane amount of money
for a a rock that is actually quite
abundant yeah but the beers owns
everything
yeah and
I think she's being
um you know kind of careful and not
hurting her friends feelings and she
only does so when they won't shut up
about it right
I I feel like there's definitely a um
they're being presented with something
that they think is valuable yeah and
they expect all their friends to also
agree that it is valuable and once they
are confronted with someone that says
they do not agree with this then you
have to either
agree with her yeah that it doesn't have
this intrinsic value that you think it
does or you have to have some cognitive
dissonance and you'll become angry as a
defensive mechanism to maintain this
idea and as well as to justify the
reason why you spend fifty thousand
dollars on a wedding yeah I think her
friends brought this on themselves and I
I I'm thinking about analogies and I was
going to originally say like you know
does this dress make me look fat right
and you know he said no no you look
great in it right are you sure about
that are you sure about that could maybe
just a little bit and then finally
somebody's like yeah fine the dress
makes you look fat see you don't like my
dress right but I think a better analogy
would be somebody makes a kind of uh
meal a dish right and it's not very good
and it might be good for other people
but you find it kind of bland and you're
like yeah it's not really my kind of
thing and so you're eating it you're
there at the table you know you're
eating it up you're having your serving
and they're like so what do you think
and you're like yeah it's it's
interesting you know and then you know
you they keep pressing you and by the
time that you've actually like eaten the
whole bowl of their crappy chili or
whatever it is you know you find you're
finally like yeah I think it was a
little Bland I I'm not a fan I would
change the recipe oh I can't believe you
said that you know
um well look it's your own damn fault
for for pushing at it over and over and
over again I think her friends are
totally in the wrong here you know
there's a yeah was it mess around find
out oh yeah yeah yeah that that's yeah
they did it yeah they they go to her to
tell her what she actually thought and
they didn't like what she actually
thoughts like well if you didn't want to
know the answer don't ask the questions
yeah you know I'll say very quickly
because we have to wrap up soon there's
another slogan that I learned as a young
stupid man and it was one of the best
things somebody ever told me act like an
a-hole get treated like an a-hole you
know so useful so do you want to lead us
out on a uh uh final thought we've got
the words of Bill Crawford
how do you keep people from jerking your
chain don't give your chain to jerks
[Music]